even the bed was making
joke
I found something
I think I can the world's on your
imagination are probably already turning
yes Jenny and submit detail their sex
life on their honeymoon it's cringy
quirky and cute all at the same time I
know I was like I was like oh man I hope
nobody's in the Next Room
okay maybe stress how we sex them and
the sex talk doesn't stop once they
leave the bedroom as they are out and
about samit asks Ginny if she's down to
take a Kamasutra class with him and her
response might surprise you and I just
don't think I need to be taught okay
it's the confidence for me let's get
into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia I'll be
honest with you this week's episode was
a little uh what it was dry at least to
me but there are a few moments I
definitely want to chat with you about
before we get into submit and Jenny
getting it on
quickly I want to talk to you about this
couple that
still doesn't make sense to me Big Ed
and Liz for those of you who don't know
Ed is 56 and Liz is 29. they met at a
restaurant where she was a manager and
we all watched their on and off again
relationship play out on a single life
now they're engaged but they're facing
major problems one of our biggest issues
in Madonna's relationship is it's very
insecure with himself and he gets so
defensive and bossy which can come off
as controlling in this week's episode
Liz reveals Big Ed suggested she needs
to lose weight
but I went on a couple pounds since we
went together does he want you to lose
weight does he say that
not exactly but he's definitely brought
up the point of like
past pictures of myself this was my
reaction you don't lost your damn mind
when you get your damn mind you called
me he will look through photos and be
like Oh do everything about being back
to that size and it's kind of insulting
I don't feel pretty and that's kind of
like why I started dance classes like
when we broke up before because I'd see
the type of girls he was hanging out
with girl don't allow his insecurities
to rub off on you someone who is
insecure not self-aware and consciously
working on loving themselves can be a
dangerous person to be in a relationship
with I would hope that Ed would love me
no matter what I've loved him at his
heaviest and his smallest since I've
been with him
never thought I'd feel so insecure about
myself the way that I do now I can't
tell you what to do but building a
relationship with a person who does not
feel good about themselves at this point
in my journey
it's a no-go forget all of the nurturing
crap
I'm not here to fix you you can lead a
horse to water but you can't make them
drink yeah there are some special cases
where this thought process doesn't apply
but from my experience dating an
insecure man just becomes draining I
have a slightly similar story to Liz's
once I was dating this guy and he was so
handsome to me but he wasn't confident
about the way he looked and he was into
doing certain procedures to fix what he
didn't like yeah that was new for me I'm
not gonna lie I was like you're
interested in doing what dating in La
anyway one day he asked me if I was
interested in getting a certain
procedure and I got offended I was like
what are you trying to say now I'm not
against cosmetic procedures or surgery
or anything like that if that's what you
want to do do it but don't suggest
anything to me I'm not perfect but I've
worked hard to get to a place where I
love and accept myself so I'm not about
to let you take me backwards no thank
you clearly the relationship didn't last
long after that I really do think Ed and
I do bring the best out in each other he
can frustrate me and we do have issues
but I do love him
and this is why
I want to work so hard for this
relationship well good luck girl
good luck I'm gonna straighten up the
bed that you made such a mess of last
night all right let's get into Ginny and
submit these two had a wild night during
the first night of their honeymoon and I
didn't expect for them to tell us this
much about it that was not only me it
was your fault too and then the bad word
it was like oh yeah the headboard was
hitting the wall yeah headboard and even
the bed was making
kind of like
I know I was like I was like oh man I
hope nobody's in the Next Room it's
always interesting to see how different
couples approach not only their intimate
time together but discussing their
intimate moments with each other
everyone has a different approach I'm
trying to keep it PG but just read
between the lines of what I'm saying we
had a great night last night
like we were thinking to call the hotel
and then say the bed was making some
noise yeah I mean how you supposed to
explain that to them right okay never
mind leave it it's okay just keep making
noise
Abba we already know submit and Jenny
are a very unique couple something about
this moment just hammered it home for me
they have this Quirk to them that can be
a bit cringy but they're also cute to
watch in this moment they turned into
two giddy kids who just get each other
it's okay just keep making noise
well something Jenny isn't okay with is
taking a yoga Kamasutra class they
teaches you how to like keep uh
Adventure interest in your married life
or your sexual life well of course I've
heard of that it's not just uh how
important it's like how you can reach to
the moment where you can say that like
oh man this is something
it's about the best thing it can happen
in life the mid ask her if she would be
interested in learning how to take their
sex life to the next level and Jenny
said what can they teach me that I don't
already know I know that's right
I don't need to learn anything about it
I think I already know everything at
this age I think I already know
everything I need to know I don't need
to be taught anything about you're
talking about like different sex
positions and sexual things I don't know
that's what
you said you know Jenny you got to be
confident
I've seen the book obviously and to me
it's just it's a book of a bunch of sex
different sex positions
it's about the perfect position which
makes everything better and better yeah
I think like it's it's we are uh like a
young couple we just recently got
married we're a young couple like one of
us is
we are a married couple so I think it's
a perfect time to experiment it together
on a honeymoon I don't know I I just
wanna let's just make love and go to
sleep you can tell Jenny's response is
disappointing to submit it's not just uh
like getting physical or having fake
it's about uh connections if you try to
come back and say that he's the one who
feels as if he can be better in bed but
Jenny shut that down real quick and said
babe you're fine okay I think you're
fine all right
let's talk about it some more later okay
okay we'll talk like we can figure it
out oh somebody just wants to try some
new things with his wife Jenny admits
that she doesn't feel comfortable
practicing Kamasutra positions in front
of a class no thank you which is
understandable our age difference has
never been an issue for us but now I'm a
little worried about what his
expectations are of us spending time
together here yeah it's going to be
interesting to see how this age
difference continues to play out and for
all of you who are now Googling karma
sutra classes near me
you have Jenny and submit to thanks for
that enjoy alright next week Angela
lands in Nigeria to pop up on Michael
who has no clue she's coming Michael I'm
out she's taking your car apart
ever since I signed I do this man
everything went down here
Michael picked the wrong woman to scam
oh the drama see this is why it's always
best for you to move with Integrity
because when you start doing Shady stuff
what's on the other side is never pretty
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with ET because we are covering it
all I will see you next time
[Music]